>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Greetings and welcome.
I'm Libby Smigel, the dance
curator in the Music Division,
and I'm delighted to have all
of you here at today's talk
which is titled Discovering
Creative Connections,
choreographer Eric Hawkins and
composer Lucia Dlugoszewski.
First I want to introduce you
to my co-presenter, Kate Doyle,
a doctoral candidate in musicology
at Case Western Reserve University.
It is in large part due to Kate's
expertise in experimental music
and her service as a fellow in
the music division last summer
that we are able to make
this presentation today.
We'll be handing the microphone back
and forth during what we estimate
to be about a 30-minute talk,
after which we hope you'll stay
on for questions and discussion
and also look at the sampling
of fascinating materials
we've selected
from the Hawkins-Dlugoszewski
special collection which is
against the windows over there.
The papers of modern dance
choreographer, Eric Hawkins,
came to us in the Music
Division in 2001
and the materials were
organized and processed
in 2007, or about 10 years ago.
Much of the collection concerns
the Eric Hawkins Dance Company
which he founded in 1951 after
leaving the Martha Graham Company.
The collection is well-suited
to the Music Division.
A music lover and pianist from
childhood, Hawkins was dedicated
to having new music
composed and performed live
for modern dance choreography.
He commissioned numerous scores
for his company from composers
such as Toru Takemitsu,
Virgil Thompson,
Henry Cowell and Lou Harrison.
The library houses most of
those scores and this body
of commissioned music is one
of the reasons why this
collection is distinctive,
but the hidden treasure in
this collection is the material
of a musician whose work Hawkins
commissioned more than any other.
The scores and papers
of Lucia Dlugoszewski,
an experimental musician,
poet, inventor and author,
who was also Hawkins'
intellectual collaborator and wife.
Last summer Kate and I sorted
through Dlugoszewski's materials
including holograph scores, letters,
family scrapbooks, to
organize her papers
within the Hawkins collection.
Here you can see the
now complete collection
of Lucia's scores written
for the Hawkins company.
Today we're going to discuss
the dynamic partnership
of these two innovative artists.
Dlugoszewski's philosophies
about art
and aesthetics align
closely with Hawkins'.
She saw a clarity, energy and
potency in his choreography
and she strove for these elements
in her own writing and composing.
Hawkins in turn felt a
kinship of vision and purpose.
The following is an excerpt
of a letter from Hawkins
to the philosopher
F.S.C. Northrup in 1958
in which Hawkins describes
Dlugoszewski's artistry.
He writes, "Since Lucy first
came to work with me in 1951,
she has devoted herself almost
entirely to writing for the dances
in a way unprecedented in the
history of modern movement.
No artist of first rank other
than her has really collaborated
with enough knowledge or love
to fathom the problem of seeing
and hearing at the same time".
During our talk this afternoon
we will point out some
of these unique points of
collaboration in Hawkins
and Dlugoszewski's creative
relationship and a bit about Eric.
Much of Eric's background,
education and early experience
in the performing arts would
shape his creative trajectory.
Born in Trinidad, Colorado,
Frederick Hawkins was raised
in the Midwest, actually
Kansas City, Missouri,
by his working-class parents.
A hard worker who distinguished
himself in science, math and music
in the public high school.
Fred, as he was then called,
joined the rarefied
university culture at Harvard.
There he found his preparation
deficient against that
of his Harvard peers, so he
turned to classical studies.
Already proficient in Latin, he
immersed himself in Greek drama
and lyric poetry, mythology
and philosophy in aesthetics,
studies that influenced his
understanding of the functions
of art, his preferences for
flow in movement and his search
for unity between music and dance.
He discovered dance
after university.
Ultimately he would find kindred
spirits in the Greek aesthetics
of Isadora Duncan and reverence for
Asian culture that the [inaudible].
But initially Hawkins was intrigued
by German expressionist
choreographers.
He was counseled by
one, Harald Kreutzberg,
to discipline his untrained body in
ballet before pursuing modern dance.
There it is.
Ballet training in New York led to
his performing with Ballet Caravan
under George Balanchine, who also
gave Eric his first opportunities
to choreograph.
Shown here on the left is his first
known choreography titled Showpiece
and on the right a playful solo
for himself performed
to a Mozart [inaudible].
He returned to the modern dance
by becoming the first male dancer
in Martha Graham's company.
Here you see Eric in two of
Martha's adaptations of Greek myths.
These photographs, however,
also depict what Eric rejected,
what he called neurotic
treatment of Greek myths,
a kind of melodramatic enactment.
Hawkins' treatment of Greek
classicism instead showed respect
for the beauty of the human body
and an organic way of movement
which had inner intensity and
feeling rather than outer tension.
The photograph of Great Dreams
on the left shows the seemingly
effortless flow of a leap.
On the right is a puckish
Hawkins behind the minotaur's mask
from his work, The
Opening of the Eye.
Hawkins' period of choreographic
activity at Ballet Caravan
and during his Graham
years did develop a way
of choreographic note taking, early
evidence of which we can see written
within this score for Eric
Standt's [phonetic], Steven Acrobat.
You can barely see now
the faded pencil notes
in the empty staff lines, a
combination of description,
spatial diagrams and dance
figures, and we have a page of that
over on the side if you
want to take a closer look
because I don't think you could
probably see that faded pencil
from your back seats there.
Yet lacking, however, was an
effective creative process
for working with composers.
In the case of Steven Acrobat,
Hawkins had encouraged composer
Robert Evett to experiment
with time signatures and tempos, a
request Evett followed so willingly
that Graham's conductor, Louis
Horst, declared it unplayable
and undanceable in the
rehearsal time allotted.
Evett reluctantly simplified
the score to what he described
as undistinguished, the harmony
stock, the counterpoint nonexistent
and etc. and on and on, concluding
with this damning sentence -
"I haven't shown it to
any of the musicians here,
professional or student".
Which brings us to 1951 as Hawkins
sought to form his own company
and find a composer with whom
he could develop a collaborative
process for music and dance creation
- and I pass the podium to Kate.
>> This is Lucia "Lucy"
Dlugoszewski,
who was born in Detroit in 1925.
She was the only child
of Polish immigrants.
Her father was a dye maker at
a Detroit auto body workshop
and her mother was a homemaker.
They both encouraged Lucia to
pursue her artistic interests,
and they themselves were
amateur artists and philosophers.
After studying science and
mathematics in college,
she received a fellowship
from the Berkshire Foundation
in the late 1940s to live
and study in New York
with the pianist [inaudible] as well
as composers Edgard
Varese and John Cage.
We are able to know about
this time in her life
from her almost daily
letters to her parents,
sometimes more than once a day.
These are now housed in our archives
here at the Library of Congress.
Here is an excerpt from one letter.
It's difficult to see
but you can maybe notice
that she's describing a birthday
party that her roommate Mary threw
for her, and she lists the attendees
at the party and they include Mary,
Miss Sultan, that's [inaudible]
Sultan, John Cage and Edgard Varese.
These letters also reflect her
developing philosophy about art
and sound and her early experiment
with found sound objects
and composition.
This is one of my favorite letters
and it's an excerpt from a letter
to her father in which she explains
the nature of her composition
and defends why it is not
reliant on beautiful melodies.
She says it's just like it was
for the people in Galileo's time,
who always thought that the world
was flat, and then he told them
that the world was round.
In 1950, 1951, Dlugoszewski met
Hawkins because his studio was next
to her teacher [inaudible]
Sultan's space.
And Sultan recommended Dlugoszewski
as an accompanist and composer
for Hawkins' newly formed company.
Here's another letter
in which Lucia writes
to her mother describing an
early interaction with Eric.
Here she's saying that she's going
to meet Hawkins and Martha Graham
to work with them on a new piece.
In another letter she
writes to her mother,
she describes her growing
friendship with Eric Hawkins
and she includes a picture of him.
We don't have that picture
unfortunately in our collection.
We have a very early score of
Dlugoszewski's from the first years
of her companionship with Hawkins.
They became fast friends and
they shared each other's contacts
in the art world and New York City.
This is one of those early scores.
It's from about 1952.
It was dedicated to their friends,
Mary and Ralph [inaudible],
that was Mary, Lucia's
former roommate.
Ralph [inaudible] was a sculptor in
New York City and they had a loft
in which artists would come to
perform and this was a score
to one of those performances.
You can see here that
she's using a variety
of found instruments including
glass rolled on a frying pan,
beans poured, silver dropped, water
splashed and crushed cellophane.
This would not be the last
time that Lucia used found
or self-fashioned instruments
to accommodate the unique sound.
In fact [inaudible], the [inaudible]
of this piece, designed a number
of percussion instruments
specifically
for Dlugoszewski to play.
Some of them are featured
in this photograph here.
That is Lucia and she's playing some
of Ralph [inaudible] instruments
that he designed for her.
After Dlugoszewski began
composing for Hawkins,
she did indeed devote herself
almost entirely to his company.
She was specifically
attracted to his way of dancing
and designing movement that
enacted a present vital
theatrical experience.
In 1963 she wrote "In my experience
the most beautiful answers
for theater came from Eric Hawkins
because he asked the most beautiful
questions not only of movement
and choreography and design,
but also of music and sound.
The elegance of his questions and
the innocence of his answers made
for a wonderful playfulness
of theater
that could challenge
music for many decades.
The transparent movement poetry of
his theater demanded a sensitivity
from sound that music
seldom pursued."
Dlugoszewski had been
searching for such questions
and answers regarding
theater and sound herself,
a quest that she describes in her
notes on New Music For The Dance,
an essay written for
Dance Observer in 1957.
The Library of Congress
holds an earlier version,
a more complete draft of this essay.
In the essay she establishes that
for her music is a form of theater.
She identifies Gertrude
Stein as "prophet of theater"
because Stein identifies
two important ideas.
One, the conveyance of
time in a motion via sight
and sound rather than
story and action.
Two, temporal immediacy, where
the idea of a theater happening
and sensed only in the
present and immediate moment.
That is why Gertrude Stein
theater is so exciting Lucia says.
It forces the instant
by instant quality
of making something happen
before your eyes moment by moment
with the constant preclusion
of image fixing
since each future instant
is unpredictable.
Just as Stein accomplishes
this immediacy with image then,
Dlugoszewski sets out to
do the same with sound.
She's influenced by Eastern
philosophy and poetry
which she says helps to promote
this radical immediacy through its
"total commitment to the aesthetic
component, to [inaudible],
to the dimension of
aliveness and consciousness".
She's also influenced by James
Joyce's descriptions of epiphany
which she calls unexpected
pure moments in which all time
and consciousness is subsumed
in one dynamic immediate
moment of sensation and being.
For Dlugoszewski, Hawkins'
choreography
and artistic process
accomplish all of these kinds
of immediacy and clarity.
She admires the way that Hawkins
creates all of his choreography
in silence, then works
to incorporate sound.
In her notes on New Music
For The Dance she writes
"Modern dancers make beautiful
use of the archaic position
when they choose to
search their own identities
in silence before the
sound is added."
All of Eric Hawkins
choreography is composed this way
and when she says archaic position
she means an older kind of theater,
one that embraces this kind
of in the moment aesthetics.
What underlines Hawkins'
choreography,
and indeed everything
Dlugoszewski says is pulse.
Heard or unheard her
pulse is always there.
Choreography, especially that of
Hawkins', makes use of this pulse
because it comprises
movement organized
through time and metrical structure.
Dlugoszewski calls the organizing
principle of this pulse structure
of the pulse, a kind of
compositional baseline
for his choreography and her works.
The pulse creates a neutral
and delicate ground upon
which to build other sonic material
such as pitch, rhythm and dynamic.
All of these elements
Dlugoszewski writes are juxtaposed
against a backdrop of timbre.
The building of musical material
allows for the kind of immediacy
that Dlugoszewski desired in
her composition as she writes:
"Music composed on the
structure of the pulse is music
that happens instant by instant
on the ground of each pulse
and so each instant of hearing
becomes momentarily the nonrelative
instant of sound poetry".
So her music resides
in and beyond time.
Every pulse with its accompanying
sonic elements should be able
to exist as a work
on its own she says.
She writes "Each pulse is separated
from the rest by an envelope
of timbre so that each moment
could be performed alone,
could possibly qualify
as the sudden instant".
Former Hawkins dancers
confirm that Dlugoszewski sat
in Hawkins' rehearsals and took
notes while his dancers danced
at first in silence.
Several pages of her notes that
we hold here in the Library
of Congress, allow insight into the
stage of Dlugoszewski's process.
So you'll see here a number of
notes from the piece Early Floating
and in this example Dlugoszewski
writes down metrical counts,
then later on she applies
subdivisions
and then finally she starts
building that composition
by layering timbre
and instrumentation.
This way of composing Dlugoszewski
says is the only one that allows
for dance to exist
in its own movement.
She feels that though connected
to the music, the dance thrives
as a theater all on its own,
separate from the theater
of the sound, and the beauty
of the experience comes
from the two theaters
existing side-by-side
in the immediate moment.
The music is not superimposed
on the dance, she insists,
but rather works alongside
it simultaneously,
and in its most compelling instances
exists in radical juxtapositions.
As you can see here,
music took on a sort
of spatial dimension
for Dlugoszewski.
It increasingly did so as she
moved into the 1960s and 70s
and her compositional
style became solidified.
After 1960 she experimented
with composing via a
kind of x/y graph system.
Hitch could be mapped
onto a vertical line,
meter and rhythm could
be mapped horizontally.
She says "It would seem that high
and low or an up-and-down journey
of which the many various scales all
over the world are very
special gradations or graphs".
We see an example of this mapping
procedure in a score of her piece,
Angels of the Inmost Heaven,
and we have actually an example.
We have a score for you
here laid out on the table,
but I want to point out a couple
of interesting things about this.
So this falls in the first
two pages of the score
and then the score is notated
as you would expect
another score to be notated.
It's fairly traditional, but here
you can see she's using this sort
of x/y graph.
On the bottom there
are markings of time.
On the side there are
markings of dynamic
and in this next instance you see
pitch, so midrange, high, very high
and then low, gradations of low.
These markings in the middle
indicate a kind of decay,
so the circles are
where the note is struck
and then she allows
the note to decay.
The piece co-titled
Densities, Supernova,
Corona and Clear Core is built
on Dlugoszewski's distribution
of sonic materials across a
designated time and space.
I want to play an example from
this so that you can hear the score
and what I'd love for you to listen
to is listen to how each sort
of phrase and each note decays.
You can actually hear the decay
of all of the individual pitches.
[ Music ]
For Dlugoszewski, sonic and
gestural materials move, juxtapose,
consolidate and evaporate
based on density.
They wane and grow in time.
In pieces such as Angels
of the Inmost Heaven,
the composer exploits a huge
scale of timbrel possibility,
usually through stretching
the limits
of the instrumentalist to a maximum.
From what she calls static,
the pinnacle of timbrel density
to extreme clarity or transparency,
words that she uses very often
in her writing and scores.
Adjustments along this timbrel
scale are most often presented
in terms of gesture and movement.
Again, she always roots
sonic elements
in physical sensational materiality.
Her conception of sound
then is tied directly
to Hawkins' [inaudible]
practice and philosophy.
Both artists use material, moving
bodies of sound and moving bodies,
within and along the ebb
and flow of rhythm and time.
The density and transparency of
timbre and space and the growth
and wain of energetic production.
Just as their conceptions of
gesture and sound are organic
in their development over
time, so was their partnership,
evident through the synthesis
of their creative process.
Dlugoszewski continued
this compositional work
on a greater basis after
Hawkins died in 1994 and she took
over the company as its director.
She herself died six years
later after suffering
from a congestive heart condition,
but she left a vibrant body of work,
a repertoire revolutionary
in its synthesis
of sonic and gestural elements.
Hawkins' and Dlugaszewski's papers,
which live together in the archives
of the Library of Congress,
reflect a dynamic partnership
and an innovative perspective on the
sculpting of sound for modern dance.
>> This -- thank you for being here
and this ends the formal component
of our talk and discussion and
I hope that this little taste
of the materials that show
the richness of the Hawkins
and Dlugoszewski collaboration
might give you some thoughts
about questions to ask or
thoughts about how they were able
to sustain this kind of
creative collaboration
over more than four decades.
One thing to note perhaps
is that Eric Hawkins was one
of three male dancers who left the
Martha Graham Company and branched
out in a kind of rejection of
the way of composing dances,
the subject matter, the technique,
the other two being Merce
Cunningham and Paul Taylor.
Both Merce and Paul Taylor
have survived both --
you know even though Merce has
now passed on as has John Cage,
the repertoire is being performed.
Paul Taylor's company is still
active, and we might wonder why
with this kind of vibrant
creativity,
how it came that the
Hawkins-Dlugoszewski approach didn't
manage to get the kind of following
and I have some ideas myself
and you may have some, and I know
we have at least one person here
who has met both Lucia and Eric
and may have some thoughts herself
as a creative artist, but it
is unfortunate that this body
of work is really not being
celebrated or even taught often
as part of dance history these days.
And as far as Lucia's
music, because Eric required
that she not publish her scores,
he didn't want to be beholden
to the music publishing industry
charging unreachable amounts
of money to perform what was really
created for his company as well,
we may have the only reel to
reel recordings which were used
for rehearsals as well as the
scores themselves and that
in itself makes it more
difficult for people to access it.
But I'm hopeful that by the end
of this summer we'll have
our finding aid online
so that you can look further
into what it is we have.
This is just a small amount and
perhaps you have some comments
or thoughts that you'd
like to share.
[ Inaudible ]
>> If you could just wait for the
microphone, sorry, we're recording.
>> And this is [inaudible]
Withers, professor of dance
at George Washington University
and I took her dance history
class the one time she offered it,
never to do it again.
It was -- I thought everyone
did it that way [laughing].
>> Anyway, Eric was a great
influence on my life for sure
because I was very young when
I met him and the first person
that I met was Anna Halperin and
then when I went to study with her
in San Marin County I was just 18
and it was the first summer
dance [inaudible] that they had
with John Cage and Merce
Cunningham coming to the Will
and Lathrop Studio in San Francisco
and she was starting to work
on Lawrence Halperin and right now
at the National Building Museum
there's a Lawrence Halperin
exhibition that shows them on
the deck and some of the drawings
that show where the
dancing is to take place.
So in the midst of that introduction
coming from doing tap dance and jazz
and bad ballet, I was quite in awe
really of all of this information.
The important -- it's
just so many things
with Eric, some very funny stories.
He insisted that of course people
didn't need to wear brassieres
or shoes or anything else that
would compromise the beauty
of the human body and he felt very
strongly about that and so one
of the jokes that he and I
had together was he smoked
and I said well I'll give up
my brassiere when you give
up your cigarettes if
that's a good deal.
I needed a brassiere [laughing], but
his tremendous interest in nature
and the human body as a gorgeous,
beautiful instrument of life
and passion and Lucia
was a small, quiet woman,
and one of the stories I remember
from her was when she was living
in Europe as a child without money
and she said her parents
would take her every week
when possible, wait
outdoors for her.
She would go into Symphony
Hall to learn
about music and what music was.
So she came from a
traditional background of music
so I think it's even more
astounding that both Lucia
and I think John Cage, that
inclination toward revising writing
about music and what
symbolic ways there were
to actually record
and motivate sound.
His technique was extremely
sort of a rejection
of Martha Graham's technique but
it had a lot of the same elements,
work on the floor and
sitting in a sort
of forward/backward leg situation.
However, his work was extremely
intricate, very nuanced
and very, very demanding.
And I think one of the things
about why maybe his work
and their work didn't continue
was it was very intricate
and delicate and very, very exact.
And that was the time when the
generations, my generation sort
of heading toward more
blatant forms of movement
and more easily achieved forms of
movement, and I taught his technique
for several years until nobody
wanted to learn it anymore
because it took too much time,
too much demand, too much beauty,
too much philosophy,
just too much philosophy.
And so even the dancers
that danced with them,
many of them my good friends,
they had to sort of give
up teaching it too, so there's not
a lot of it being taught today.
It does happen though.
There's a lot of people teaching
his technique in New York
and I think important, important
that it has been quite a mystery
to me too that two of my very
good friends, Alvin Nicolai
and this beautiful duo,
they were never accepted
and never acknowledged for
some reason I never understood.
And I'll tell one more story which
I think is pretty interesting.
Anna Halperin was in Washington
and I had agreed to present her
at Marvin Theater at TW and at
that time Watts had had the --
Watts was on fire we'll say,
and so she brought together a
multi-cultural group of people
that studied and danced together
all day every day to sort of look
at what was happening in our culture
that made this terrible chasm
between the cultures of Koreans
and African-Americans and so forth.
And so she wanted to be
presented in Marvin Center
and Eric had asked me see if I could
present them in Lisner Auditorium.
And he wanted to do his sort
of nude dance at the time
and she was asking -- they
were dancing naked as well.
They had all their rehearsal
sessions naked in California
and so I said well I know that
I can't do it at Marvin Center
because it's a theater in the round
and people can reach out and touch
and I felt it was a little dangerous
for me to put my reputation
on the line and so I
said no to Anna Halperin.
She had been arrested in New York
City as those of you that recall,
and she had to leave New
York City to not be arrested,
and then she was performing
in Washington,
and then Eric Lisner was
performing and when I went there
and I saw the work and I said
well this is not a nude ballet
and he said well yes
it is, certainly it is,
because the women were naked.
The men were wearing a covering,
a jockstrap, and he said well
who would ever want to dance
without that being held
into place [giggling] and I
said well a lot of women might
like looking at that [laughter],
maybe the men might not,
but anyway there are
some wonderful stories
and really Lucia just
watching her on stage,
because she performed
in a visible way.
She taught me that because I've had
only live music for about 120 works
that I've created, all music
played live for the work,
and that takes you to
improvisational artists a lot rather
than people who do notation and
so forth, but I think watching her
on stage live while
they were performing
so profoundly influenced
my life that I always knew
that a musician needed to be seen
so we could watch their movement
and watch the concentration
of their mind
and the way they felt
for the performance.
And she taught me that, and
watching her was quite an incredible
experience honestly.
And he's a big man.
You can see then from the images of
him his large thigh and so forth.
And I have only one
more story, I apologize.
This is like reminiscence for me
because nobody knows who he is
so to speak and when you
teach them the people look
at you like where are you from?
I've never seen any books about
this or I've never seen any videos
or films of this and
so something got left
out that was really,
really important.
But I was teaching at Howard
University the first year I moved
to Washington, DC, and he came
there to do the piece about --
what's the name of it --
out here in West Virginia
where it was -- someone took --
>> John Brown or --
>> John Brown.
>> Or God's Angry Man.
>> Yeah, John Brown, you all
know the story of John Brown,
and so Eric Hawkins came out on
the stage at Howard University
and started talking and he talked
and he philosophized and he talked
and he talked more and 45 minutes
later he was still talking.
And little by little the audience
had left and there was really
about 20 of us left because he
just insisted that conceptual ideas
and philosophy should be able to be
talked about with dance, that dance
and that had a deep
reservoir of relationship.
So I know he was accused a lot of
talking too much about philosophy,
but if you took his class you'd
stand in place and wait and watch
and watch and wait and be
there and be there and be there
and be there while he talked about
the body and about philosophy.
And so now we had a --
dance is very physical.
It's very athletic.
People are impatient.
They want to learn quickly.
It's a different time than
that, so anyway, thanks.
>> Thank you [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> The other thing that has
your comments reminded me --
especially talking about
Alan Nicolai and the two
of them not being celebrated
the way they are.
They really didn't have a technique
that was codified and of course
when we think about Martha Graham
technique or Balanchine technique,
they've even tried to copyright it
or trademark it, and really it was
about using the body
is an instrument much
as she was using musical
instruments in different ways
than perhaps you had
been taught by technique.
So the technique if it
were called the technique
and maybe we should be calling it,
was really about what do we need
to do to create what the artist
is imagining rather than lots
of physical exercises
and I think for both
of them it's meant less
transmission and so --
>> A really important thing
about his technique is
that he wanted beauty.
He really wanted beauty
to be the basic thing
that you were [inaudible] and not
sexual beauty or not indulgent --
>> Yeah, he used the word
sensuous in that sense.
>> Very abstract, pure
form of beauty and power
and I think it's idealistic and
maybe unrealistic for most of us.
>> I think probably -- although when
you hear her scores probably a lot
of you didn't feel well
that is beautiful music.
I would not be playing
that to go to bed
and get a good night's
rest necessarily.
It was more active because it's
not -- it isn't predictable.
So it's an interesting, even a
definition of what is beauty,
and I think that's part
of the challenge too
that really shakes our
premises of what is possible.
Other thoughts?
Yes.
>> I'm going to put this down.
Can you hear me?
[ Inaudible ]
>> My name is Gregory
Velasco [phonetic].
In 1968 I read Isadora
Duncan's "The Art of the Dance"
and I decided that's the kind of
dancing that I was going to do,
but I wasn't going to
repeat what she did.
I wanted to do the
germ of what she did.
Several years later I was on a
train with Carla Perloyle [phonetic]
up to the American Dance Festival
and I was trying to decide what kind
of dancing I was going to do because
Cunningham didn't fit the bill
for me, Limone sort of did,
and she said well you probably
should do Lester Horton
because you're so big and she
says whatever you do stay away
from Eric Hawkins.
So I thought well that's exactly
what I'm going to go towards
and I read an essay he wrote and
the intelligence with which he wrote
about Isadora Duncan's vision
of transcendental eroticism
and the body caught me.
I went to study with
Nancy Mayhan for two years
and she was his partner early in
the 60s, and then I went to study
with Hawkins himself for 12 years
at his studio and supplemented
with Miriam Rosen's instruction
at the University of Maryland.
I have never done anything else.
I refused to subject my body to it.
As a result, I was able to model
the technique at the 92nd Street "Y"
in New York in -- let's
see, it was in 2010,
and I modeled until about a
year ago and I'm 61 years old.
As a result of his tutelage
I have been able to dance
for a very long time and to actually
better myself in my dancing.
I'm dancing better than
I did at 20 or 30 or 40.
The body is certainly not
in the same shape it was
but the spirit is there and
the body is actually willing.
I owe a great debt to
him for what he did
for the enormous amount
of work he did.
I'm sorry I missed the beginning
of your discussion here,
but he had a vision of the body
which in America has
always been difficult.
America never accepted Isadora
Duncan until after she died.
These are people who were a
little bit ahead of the game.
He was low impact before
low impact was [inaudible].
He was dealing with
biomechanics before [inaudible].
He had a book which he used
to quote from all the time
which is very interesting
called "The Thinking Body"
by Mabel Ellsworth-Todd, where
you actually stood with the image
of the dancer you wanted today
and you saw yourself
eventually become that.
>> No its -- thank you so much.
That's a really wonderful comment
because he's sometimes known
for that low impact and the adoption
of kinesiology principles before
it really affected other dancers
and everyone in the history seems to
say well he had an injury and he had
to seek something but it's so
clearly aligned with a larger vision
that yes it does mean that you've
taken care of your Stradivarius
so that you can dance or
play it four your full life
and he also though was
subjected sometimes to criticism,
that his free-flowing leaps
weren't those that we think
of for Baryshnikov at his
height or something, but --
>> The body for him was --
[ Inaudible ]
>> Well there are a few because
we have some here [laughter]
which is fabulous.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you Gregory.
>> I have a question for you.
I'm wondering just a bit
more about the collection,
in particular the notation.
Transmission of these
pieces you mentioned
that there's some standard notation
and also mapping pitches
differently and things like that.
Maybe you could just speak a bit
more about the different ways
that that information is both
transmitted to the musicians
and to the dancers and
how that intersects.
>> Thank you so much.
That's an excellent question.
So if you look through the scores in
this collection, by and large most
of them are traditionally notated.
The example that I showed you here
was unusual and it allows us insight
into her process, how we get
from the early floating sketches
that I showed you to the
traditionally notated scores
that you'll find in
most of this collection.
So in terms of transmission to
the dancers, from my knowledge
of Lucia's process,
she was again sitting
in these rehearsals watching
Eric go through the choreography
with his dancers, and there
are other people who can speak
to this much more articulately
than I can,
but I can just tell you what
I've found from Lucia's scores.
So she's taking notes,
she's building
on what she calls the structure of
the pulse, this kind of baseline,
and then she's layering
these sonic materials.
This is what I think
is just so exciting,
that she's using these
musical elements.
We think of timbre rhythm, whatever,
these regular musical elements,
and she's using them in
a totally sculptural way.
She's literally building them one
on top of another and she talks
about them in her extensive writings
in a very material
and sculptural way.
So she's synchronizing
herself with Eric in that way.
She really is writing for the dance
in a totally revolutionary
way in my opinion.
But back to your question about
the scores, yes most are --
end up being traditionally notated
but examples like this get us
as scholars to provide
insight into that process.
>> And also they are
heavily annotated.
Initially we see more choreographic
notes or cues, but ultimately
as she's becoming more
sophisticated in the way
that she's preparing the scores,
you'll see put hairpin in mouth,
these little cues where you know
that there's something that's
being prepared, sort of the notes
to herself to make sure that that
next special effect or density
or timbre, whatever
it is, is prepared.
But she was active.
I mean what [inaudible]
said is very true,
that she was almost choreographed
in the sense that she had
to be doing these other things.
>> And actually -- so we
have an example of one
of the really valuable
things about the scores
and about this collection
is that she performed
as [inaudible] mentioned,
she was on stage or close
to the stage when she performed.
So some of these are her performance
parts so we have a part of hers,
the piano part, which she
called the timbre piano
which we did not have
time to talk about today,
but it was basically a kind of
prepared piano although it was sort
of like a compilation of
prepared piano plus sort
of almost a found object sculpture
in which she was using things
like jars and placing
wild, unusual things --
combs and things like
that, inside the piano.
So we have one of her
parts from Black Lake,
that's the timbre piano part, and
this is what Libby was referring
to when she says -- she's
written in put hairpin in mouth.
So she had the hairpin somewhere
in the piano and then she's --
it's almost like a kind
of choreography in itself
because she's negotiating the jars
and the combs and all the stuff
that she's putting in -- she's
putting in the piano and taking out.
So I would advise all
of you to look at it.
It's just such a fabulous
slice of history there
and such a beautiful example of
the kind of innovative things
that she was doing
just all on her own,
literally right there in the moment.
So it's over there on the table.
>> Did that answer most of your
question or did you also want
to know about like the
choreographic notation?
Okay, most of his dances
are not [inaudible],
which is a very formal system
that you get a certified person.
But what we do have is
astonishing notebooks,
usually more than one,
of Eric's process.
So he starts with notes.
Sometimes these are narrative
things copying from poetry or ideas,
and then it starts going into
little movement motifs and he had
that strange way of creating
a little bit of narrative,
a little bit of stick figure,
and then these things started
to jog his memory and then
they become more and more --
maybe we could scroll
up to one of those
which I didn't really
have time to talk about.
But you kind of see here it's very
faint but he would divide these,
make these columns which are
[inaudible] notation effect
because [inaudible] notation scores
actually have the person start --
the notation starts at the bottom
and it works forward the way we go
sort of forward so it doesn't go
from top to bottom but from the
back, the bottom to the top.
And on the left-hand side
he has notes about space
and so you can see the sort
of curly cues over there
so that each one marked by which
dancer and then he has columns
for each dancer and so he has
these and by the end of his career
and his life he had taught a lot of
his dancers to be able to read these
and also to make notes
in the same system.
So we still have some people
who are amongst us who are able
to reconstruct pretty well and
you see these notes on the side.
There's a little square box here,
those little squares have numbers
in them and those have the
pulses, they are counting,
and one of the dancers, Laura
Pettibone, who actually lives
in southeastern Virginia right
now and is working on a biography
of Hawkins, said that we
were counting all the time
because there weren't
traditional time signatures.
And of course we know
that that was the thing
that got Louis Horst
[phonetic] upset in one
of Eric's first experiments
trying to commission,
that all these time signatures,
it didn't matter with Lucia
because she had it all in
these pulses which meant
that it was countable for
the dancers and it wasn't
about switching from
3-8 to 3-4 and --
>> The interesting thing about the
mutual construction of the music
and the dance -- the music
and dance were actually
constructed separately.
They agreed on the pulses
and then they went off
and did their own thing without
any kind of communication.
This is similar, I was there,
this is similar to what Cage
and Cunningham did but
slightly different.
As they started to converge they
finally began to come together.
It became very difficult to dance
the dances because the subdivisions
of the beat which are a major detail
of this work often were different
within the pulse so you would
have a subdivision of six going
on in Lucia's music and you have
a subdivision of eight going
on in Eric's dance [chuckling], so
you had to have that pulse going.
>> Time for one more
if anyone's got one --
>> I don't have anything
intellectually to offer you,
but was Eric Hawkins on tour
at college towns around 1972?
Does anybody know that?
>> Yes, in the age of
touring, the 60s and the 70s,
it looks as though he was just
going wherever he had an offer.
I don't know how they all managed
to stay awake and stay alive.
>> I actually saw Eric
Hawkins in 1972
in my college town at
Indiana University --
>> Very likely.
I could -- if you gave me the --
>> When I saw this lecture
today my memories --
you know the box came back and
it had quite an impression.
I can tell you just
from a layman's point
of view the man was very muscular.
The music was very, very
bizarre at the time, in 1972.
I have to tell you
sadly people walked out,
a lot of people walked out.
I do recall him with trees
being carted around the stage
and I do recall that the man
had a very muscular body.
>> Thank you.
>> That's my reaction to Eric --
>> And if you let me
know how to contact you,
I've been organizing the
programs and that's where I saw --
just I don't know what small
college he hadn't performed at.
He had such support.
I'd be happy to photocopy the
program and let you take a look
at it to jog your memory further.
But you also mentioned the trees and
nature was a huge effect, influence,
on both Lucia whose
mother was a gardener,
and we have Lucia's
mother's scrapbook,
and also Eric because he
loved the Southwest states.
He had originally been in Colorado
and of course studying
classics and others.
There's a very important sort of
spiritual connection to nature
as well and so they were making
masks and dancing the giant squash
and all sorts of very
[inaudible] ideas [chuckling].
Thank you.
>> Well I saw the entire concert.
I didn't walk out but it was freaky
and I definitely remembered it.
>> [Laughing] Thank you.
And I just want to thank Kate
Doyle who came down from Cleveland
and Case Western Reserve so that she
could share her research with you
and thank you very much for coming
and if you have a few minutes
to see the exhibits here
that would be delightful.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.